ROBERT BALLARD: The
Titanic was really
a cover for a highly
classified military operation
to investigate two nuclear
submarines that we lost
during the Cold War
with all hands, the USS
Thresher and the USS Scorpion.
They ironically turned
out to be on either side
of where the Titanic was lost.
And quite honestly, had
that not been the case,
you wouldn't be looking at the
guy that found the Titanic.
The Navy wanted
complete, 100% photo
documentation of
both wreck sites
and to answer some questions.
What are the nuclear
reactors doing?
What's the status
of nuclear weapons?
Is there any evidence the
Soviets have been there.
Well, I said to both the
Secretary of the Navy John
Lehman and Admiral Thunman who
was my boss as a Naval officer,
well, what if we use the
Titanic as the cover?
N. RONALD THUNMAN: I thought
it was a cockamamie story.
I mean, find the Titanic.
ROBERT BALLARD: And I said,
well, it'd be a great cover,
wouldn't it?
Finally he said, thumbs up.
N. RONALD THUNMAN: I told
him, do whatever you want,
just don't spend any more money.
ROBERT BALLARD: Boy,
did I work fast.
We pretty well knew what
happened to the Thresher.
We mapped her a year earlier.
They knew very little
about the Scorpion.
It took me about a week
to get there and map it.
We mapped it extensively.
And there was no evidence
of human remains.
I mean, that would have
been tough, but no.
The reactors were intact,
so that was good because.
N. RONALD THUNMAN: There were no
other indications of something
amiss other than the
submarine had gone down
and it had imploded.
ROBERT BALLARD: As soon
as the Navy was satisfied,
we headed northwest
for the Titanic.
I had 12 days to hunt.
But I had learned something from
the Thresher and the Scorpion
that I couldn't tell anyone,
because both submarines
imploded before they
came to the bottom.
So on their way down [clap]
the pressure holes went.
And that implosive event
is a gigantic explosion.
And it just blew the
submarines apart.
But when I was mapping
it, we realized
that the heavy stuff went down
like a bowling ball, reactors--
boom.
But then the lighter stuff
was a big, long line.
And I went, didn't the
Titanic do the same thing?
So let's not look for the
big pieces of Titanic,
because they're only that big.
Let's look for the debris, which
meant I could space my search
lines much wider apart.
NARRATOR: But
Titanic did not lie
where she was thought to be.
Days of futile
search dragged on.
INTERVIEWER: How close
were you to failure?
ROBERT BALLARD: Well I had--
I was reaching the point of
where I thought we'd failed.
I thought we had.
And I was going--
I went back to my room,
and we had the watch going.
It was a mid-watch.
Everything happens on the
midnight watch, 12:00 to 4:00.
I don't know why.
Everything important occurs
right around midnight.
Wreckage Bingo, yeah.
FEMALE: Did you find it?
MALE: [inaudible]
somebody [inaudible]..
And I went in,
and there it was.
I mean, the boiler
was on the screen.
Oh, I love it I love it.
I'll be [bleep].
The sucker exists.
Hey, does Kathy
got the champagne?
N. RONALD THUNMAN: We
were jumping up and down.
We were patting one
another on the back.
And then someone looked at the
clock in the command center
and said, she sinks
in 20 minutes.
It was 2:00 in the morning.
She sank at 2:20.
And that innocent
comment just grounded us.
And we realized, you
have finally put to rest
were these souls were lost.
And everyone filed out.
And it was a moment of
silence, because we were there.
And that was pretty--
pretty powerful.
[music playing]